[Musique]
aujourd'hui on cuisine vapeur
parce que c'est bon c'est facile et
surtout ses santé on connaît la
marguerite on utilise parfois les tuent
veuze mais rarement les paniers de
bambou ça nous permet une petite
versatilité un petit peu plus grande
on va pouvoir venir déposer les bouchers
déposer les morceaux de poisson ou de
viande puis faire les cuisson vapeur
mais c'est le même principe au final
c'est vraiment la vapeur il fait office
de chaleur un des avantages les étages
qui permettent de cuire différents
aliments en même temps le principe c'est
déposer un rond qui convient à la
casserole parce que ce qu'on veut c'est
garder le plus de vapeur possible qui va
traverser notre système de panier si on
en a pas évidemment on pourrait
installer ce système là dans le fond de
la casserole
on viendrait déposer nos panier vapeur
et à ce moment là pour garder le maximum
9 heures forêt venir mettre à couvert
par dessus un panier comme ça doit
valoir à peu près 1 4 dollar
vous en achetez un par personne et à la
maison chacun fait son saumon à la
saveur qui veut donc c'est une activité
en elle même on dépose le pavé de saumon
à moi je vais mettre de l'huile de césar
à moi je met du piment à moi je vais
mettre si je vais mettre ça
trois seulement trois saveurs trois
étages on commence par le saumon à la
taille
ensuite je mets le saumon au miso et
érable et je termine avec mon citron et
un tout simplement ont convoyé déjà la
vapeur et là il reste plus qu'à attendre
[Musique]
bah faut juste le faire intelligemment
plus il d'ailleurs de jus qui risque de
couler plus on va le mettre en dessous
puis on va monter dans les étages les
choses qu'on veut pas mélanger les
saveurs c'est sûr et certain que la
vapeur on sûr puis jamais beaucoup trop
donc si vous l'avez laissé 15 minutes au
lieu de 10 minutes le 5 minutes
oui aura puis la chair du saumon par
exemple mais il sera encore tendre il
sera pas c'est ça pardonne les erreurs
pas besoin de huiler le fond il faut
juste utiliser du papier tout est comme
celui ci ou simplement du papier
parchemin percée sinon feuille de salade
feuille de chou et c'est à moi dans mon
cours de danse bling on utilise des
feuilles de chou chinois qu'on dépose au
fond puisqu'il faut ce que la vapeur
puis se rendront qu'on veut rien
d'hermétique pour les légumes
d'accompagnement on empile aussi si je
sais que mon chou de bruxelles sera
moins vite près que mon brocoli mais je
le mets en dessous comme ça je vais
pouvoir retirer facilement mon brocoli
et remettre le couvercle pour poursuivre
et poursuivre la cuisson
jonathan donne aussi un atelier
culinaire avec les paniers de bambou qu
on va prendre notre pote faites vous de
la place vous allez en avoir besoin
parfait un peu de farine brioche au port
d'hommes plink pékinois ou aux crevettes
tout est cuit à la vapeur
c'est quand même dur et de puissance y
est pour le premier panique en contact
avec des casseroles essentiellement oui
tant que la vapeur travers ces traverses
de haut en bas puis on a à peu près la
même quantité donc on n'a pas vraiment
de variation après cinq six étages
peut-être mais sur trois quatre étages
là on est presque bon dans une minute ou
deux vous allez pouvoir goûter à ça
c'est bon vous avez un petit couteau
vous pouvez le coupé fait attention
c'est très chaud la principale légumes
on peut même avec les paniers faire du
dessin j'ai pris la même pâte à brioche
que j'utilise normalement avec du porte
char soul ben là j'ai eu garnier cette
pâte là avec de la banane et du chocolat
donc ça peut très bien faire une petite
bouchée déjeuner ou une bouchée pour le
goûter
quand les enfants arrivent de l'école on
a mis ça sur la vapeur puis ça
fonctionne très bien
le bambou c'est durable mais il faut en
prendre soin essentiellement à la vo
chaude savons éponge ce qu'on veut pas
c'est que ça colle ou sa caramélise mais
la vapeur fait que d'habitude derrière
nicole ou à peu près dans les paniers
donc un bon coup d'eau un peu de savon
puis c'est bon je les passerai par la
machine parce que l'exposé le bois trop
longtemps à l'eau ça sera pas ça pas une
bonne une bonne idée mais ça sèche bien
ça se conserve c'est pas très cher
c'est un accessoire de plus et moi je
l'utilisais autant comme utile de
cuisson que comme outil de présentation
c'est un outil assez le forum et au
besoin on achète des étages
supplémentaires plus la famille
s'agrandit plus en anglais si l'équipe
de tournage veut écouter
mais